well grab the popcorn folks of course
with the Uh vegan Butter alternative
depending on your personal dietary
preferences fired FBI director James
comey has been cleared to and plans to
testify publicly about the bombshell
allegations that Donald trump put
pressure on him to stop his
investigation into disgraced  former
National Security advisor Michael Flynn
which could be considered obstruction Of
Justice by president Donald trump We're
still waiting on the final details no
date has been set as of 15 minutes Ago
this will be before the senate
intelligence committee Which is
investigation possible collusion between
Donald trump and Russia you might recall
that former FBI director Robert Muller
has been brought in as a special
prosecutor for the trump Russia
investigation James comey has spoken
openly with Muller to work out
details He has been cleared to testify
what are we likely to hear or  not hear
from James It's
unlikely from a couple of reports
thaty will be willing to discuss in
detail the fbi's investigation into the
charges of possible collusion between
trump's campaign and Russia but it does
appear that James comy is going to talk
about those interactions that he  had
with Donald trump prior to his firing
including this just unconscionable If
true request from Donal trump for James
comey to kill the investigation which
comey says he refuses to do this could be
the most dramatic testimony related to
this entire scandal and There are still
people emailing  me pat says David
There's nothing there because Russia
didn't Flip the election to trump by
hacking We are 50 Stories beyond Russian
hacking to influence the results of the
election that is not the story at this
Point the story now is the unexplained
dozens upon dozens  upon dozens of lies
about meetings with Russian associates
by trump team members possible
obstruction Of Justice lack of
disclosure on and on and on I really
think this will be one of the highest
rated congressional testimonies of all
time We can almost guarantee that He's
going to confirm  trump Uh asked him to
stop the investigation into Michael
Flynn I think That's a fair Guess um but
the real question is will There be any
other Bomb shells obviously he going to
want to act
professionally not going to be able to
reveal any classified information but he
also has this Hero
people back
and La fashion never says anything Extra
and then you've got sort of like the
obviously It's not just trump Who thinks
this but the whole He's a showboat
showman whatever type of thing So you
You seem to respect But you  still do
think that his personality is some those
I don't think he ever lied ian I trust
the claims that he makes How he goes
making them that PR conference about how
he wasn't going to report
against charges Hillary Clinton that was
unprecedented here  something insane for
you to on It's only been three Weeks
since comey was fired by trump it feels
like It's been six months because every
day has three to five new or gr scandals
but it has only been three Weeks since
this entire comey fired and subsequently
you  know Stories about mem written at the
time of meeting with trump blown
up republicans going to prepare really
professionally fory testimony so that
they can really get into the details and
figure out What did happen with Hillary
clinton's emails Way Back when i or talk
about leaks I  can imagine senator corn
now Mr comey I'd like to discuss the
leaks that led to us Finding out that
you supposedly were asked by Donald
trump That's What republicans are going
to do right That's What they've done at
every single one of these meetings  and
of course John corn was considered to be
J
repl as FBI director not to happen But
you think that would hising think trump
Although ify is Talking mainly about trump
and his interactions with trump during
this hearing How is trump not going to
melt down during this  thing he'll be
tweeting all sorts of madness to both
his Real and fake Twitter followers more
on that a little bit later I actually
predict which Of course is an acronym
for observations very extinguishing for
everyone That's what I predict we will
see it'll  be full blown coby I mean
There's so many commentators and Maybe
even News agencies that will live tweet
one of these testimonies or political
events you don't really expect that from
the president no but Uh We Know he
watches TV a lot of the day So  I
wouldn't be shocked If He takes to
Twitter while This is going on Anyway
we'll let you know once we've got That
scheduled